well to the u.s presidential race now
democratic candidate joe biden is
expected to announce his choice of
running mate
next week in march he committed to
choosing a woman
as his vice president since then dozens
of names have been floated as
possibilities
in a moment we'll speak to our
washington correspondent but first
here's a look at four
top contenders for the post
one person seen as having a good chance
of becoming biden's running mate is
kamala harris
observers say she takes lots of boxes
she's a person of color something seen
as crucial
given the current russians over racism
in the us
she's also someone the public knows well
having tried to secure the democratic
nomination herself
before withdrawing to support biden in
march
crucially she has a reputation as a
fierce and competent debater
however critics fear there could be a
lack of personal chemistry
between her and biden something some say
could be a drawback for her
senator elizabeth warren is another
well-known face
she too fought a tough campaign to
become the democratic nominee
at 71 she brings experience and as biden
is demanding
the ability to do the job on day one
but her age could work against her
some also worry she could alienate
republican swing voters
by being too progressive and too liberal
then there is senator tammy duckworth a
veteran who lost both legs during the
iraq war
supporters say her military credentials
and her personal narrative
may well appeal to conservatives
frustrated with trump
as a thai american she's also from an
ethnically diverse background
and hailing from the midwest something
she could also give biden the edge when
it comes to battleground states such as
michigan
but others fear her lack of experience
on the national stage
could be a disadvantage but
another figure thought to be in
contention is former national security
adviser susan rice
the protector of north korea she also
served as u.s ambassador to the u.n
under the obama administration and as
such has a wealth of foreign policy
expertise
including on russia and china at 55
she's also relatively young but
detractors say one [ __ ] in her armor
could be
that she's never run for public office
well i'm joined now by dw's inez poll in
washington d.c
let's take a closer look at these
candidates who is seen as having the
best chance to become biden's running
mate
well i think it is camilla harris
because she's a really experienced
politician she has a very interesting
family background so
her father is a an immigrant from
jamaica her mother is an
indian immigrant so she really reaches
out to
to minorities and they will be crucial
in this
election campaign and she has been a
prosecutor which really
gives her some good points in the rather
conservative conservative part of the
democratic party
all right a woman from a diverse
background who of course also ran in the
primaries previously
what does biden's choice need to bring
to the table to give democrats the best
chances of beating president trump in
november
right claire i mean vice presidential
pigs have often been seen as
bringing kind of a strength where the
candidate has a weakness
with biden it is obviously his age but
not only that he is a man so yes he
already said that he's going to pick a
woman he needs someone who is attractive
for the spring voters for those
republicans who are just not willing to
to vote for donald trump
uh one more time he also needs someone
whom people trust who is able uh to
really
guide this country out of this economic
crisis which is just about to start
this is another really demand and after
all this person has to be able to reach
out
to those uh democrats
who really do not like joe biden so this
is a really
kind of a big variety of demands this
this person has to fulfill
all right so a number of areas where
this woman might potentially boost
biden's chances
but we don't always hear quite so much
about vice presidential candidates
why do you think there's been so much
attention to this race
well i do think it is because
after all president trump is such a
controversial
president this is really gives this
whole election campaign
such a huge worldwide i think attention
that's unusual at the first point but
then again it's also like joe biden's
age we know
that his vp pick is only a heartbeat
away from becoming a president because
it is likely that he is not able to run
for the full
uh for or to be in office for the full
four years
so likely that he doesn't only pick like
the first
female vice president but maybe he picks
the first female president
after all all right inez poll in
washington dc thank you for your
reporting